parents were not unreasonably concerned
that schools had become a place where
kids were being exposed to ideas about
gender and race that were completely
inappropriate for someone three years
old you're making my case for me they
may have been however I don't think I
think he does these things to distract
from his real policies which are
let's stop Social Security cut Medicare
you know those are the real things look
and especially in Florida 90 of the
people already on Social Security right
you're saying he's for maybe maybe the
party is he is too I mean he is too I
mean I'm less worried about him so you
know kind of glamorizing Ron DeSantis
and sure he does some crazy stuff but a
lot of it is because he's being forced
into doing it by the woke left